hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm gonna
be checking out the trailer for Hail
Caesar Coen Brothers film I'm excited
for this a because the Coen brothers
they know what they're doing let's face
it B there's a large cast assembled here
from my understanding he got Scarlett
Johansson Channing Tatum
George Clooney Josh Brolin Jonah Hill I
think yeah ray Fiennes Tilda Swinton and
most importantly Dolph Lundgren he's the
best of all these actors I listed all
right check this trailer out last Bend
Father for I have sinned
how long since your last confession my
son 27 hours it's really too often
you're not that bad here at Capitol
pictures as you know millions of people
look up for information and uplift and
yes entertainment and we're gonna give
it to
technicians and actors and top-notch
artistic people and working hard to
bring to the screen the biggest release
of the year
al sees there's a pristine picture with
one of the biggest stars in the world
Clinic Whitlock a truth we could see if
we if we somebody slipped into my door
we have your movie star gather $100,000
in the wait instructions to our week
[Music]
hello Lawrence Obie thank you all for
coming
the studio me jail Baird Whitlock has
been kidnapped spend 24 hours but we're
looking for him we don't want it in the
gossip columns it across the studio a
lot of money that's where you come in I
need some cash enesta very strong for us
is it hard squeezing it like that it's
part of the job this 20 million readers
want the truth today yes
impress your vanity recognizer this is a
drama man it's a real Islamic mr. Mannix
no sounds great if someone's calling
from the future that what
wondering what's going on what a great
looking film man it looks like a blast I
was really into that trailer dude Josh
Brolin looks like they're having such a
great time you know I love seeing George
Clooney just really have a good time you
know nothing's better than George
Clooney enjoying himself on screen that
sounds like I want to watch a masturbate
first of all I just love the tone and
style of the trailer I mean the Coen
Brothers gonna bring this 1950s world of
Hollywood to life you can just feel it
the acting and the performance is the
personality the style of the way these
characters are behaving their dialogue
it's reminiscent of a film from the 50s
but it's not over-the-top too much where
it's gonna be like a parody or a spoof
of 1950s behavior you could just feel
that that was probably the personality
of the business world that was going on
back then I mean it just feels like
classic Coen brothers to me you got this
gray cast with a totally weird [ __ ]
plot they tend to deal with things that
deal with like ransom kidnapping I know
their appeal to that kind of thing and
they do it very well I mean they got a
lot of actors that they've worked with
before I mean I'm sure I'm not gonna
list all of them properly here but you
know they worked with George Clooney a
couple of times they've worked with Josh
Brolin before they've obviously worked
with Francis McDormand before I'm
excited to see more of what Channing
Tatum's role is gonna be like from this
from right now it looks like he's having
a lot of [ __ ] fun you know he seems
like a gay sailor nothing wrong being
gay but I do have problems with sailors
[ __ ] I love the whole
production design of all at the visual
aesthetic is so [ __ ] cool I get
there's so much color to it and as a guy
who's like really a fan of cinema and I
don't really take interest in much
history but cinema history I really do
like so seeing that kind of authentic
Flair the 50s brought to life is very
exciting from one-leg myself Josh Brolin
looks like he's doing a great [ __ ] J
you know I got it I haven't seen Josh
Brolin really have that much fun and a
roll in awhile you know like last when I
remember his men
black 3 but even before that I don't
really know too many roles where I was
like Josh Brolin's having a lot of fun
with this something tells me that
because it's Coen Brothers it's probably
gonna go down a darker path as this
movie progresses but I like that the
Coen Brothers do that they always had
these films these first off their films
always have great [ __ ] trailers like
their trailers are awesome just the
trailers a lot of their movies are great
I feel like that the Coen Brothers will
do their thing where they go really dark
towards the end and it's always kind of
like a little off-putting and kind of
like shocking but if you're a fan of the
Coen Brothers you'll like it I know this
looks like vintage Coen Brothers film to
me with a grey cast I'm really excited
to see this I'm yeah keep a lookout for
my review of this movie anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe today
and become a reject we're going with
that that's what most of the comments
say go with reject follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope
because if we get enough followers we
can get even more product placement for
things such as spray bottles spray
bottles are great you know why spray
bottles are great if you've ever been to
because I haven't talked about this in a
while but a [ __ ] party that's where
you know a group of guys get together
they all come on the same chick usually
her face or body whatever you know
sometimes they like to drink it that
part not to big fan of the ology is in a
cup and they all drink it but with this
you can have an efficient [ __ ] party
if everyone just comes in a spray bottle
then you go to the girl's face and yeah
that's why I want product placement from
spray bottle companies